gang before we hit the fun button in the
episode let's talk about the good old
middle class famous tour talking
stand-up show play a little ayg with the
crowd it's a good time grab the homies
grab the bozos grab your gal grab your
guy come out and see us we're coming
everywhere yeah guys we're going to be
in denver phoenix salt lake city chicago
chicago late show at it first so sold
out then we're going to be in rosemont
oh baby
then we're going to pittsburgh buffalo
and detroit and june get those tickets
we'll see you there
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash
now here are your hosts kevin ryan and h
foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is ru garbage yeah it is it's a little
show we sit down with your favorite
comedians and we find out they got to be
classy yeah which are just a big old
piece of trash
i'm your host states foley here with my
partner in crime mr kevin james ryan
hello as you know we were down there in
austin texas recently at the moon tower
comedy festival jayhawks doing a live
podcast happen to land a big big fish
who's that
you know them you love them we're gonna
get to them right now live from austin
texas ladies and gentlemen a very
special episode of are you garbage with
mr pete holmes enjoy yeah
thanks for coming out everybody we
appreciate it
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
as you know those numbers are
[ __ ] baby and then obviously i'd be
an [ __ ] a jerk off an idiot if i
didn't mention the greatest website of
all time www.patreon.com
ru garbage check it the [ __ ] out love
that money and having a nice quick shout
out give him a round of applause t-bone
mcmuffin toby mcmullen everybody
t-bone
we love you pal
gang we could not be more excited and i
mean more excited to have our incredibly
special guest here with us today for the
first time he is a very funny very
successful stand-up comedian actor
podcaster producer talk show host and
tall drink of water if i might say so
myself you've seen them in but not
limited to get ready for this
ugly americans marin kroll show mullany
american dad animals don't think twice
fantasy hospital bob's burgers adam
ruins everything he got 24 episodes of
crashing which he created and wrote 15.
holy [ __ ]
then we're talking about the secret life
of pat's two we're talking about star
wars resistance the simpsons also wrote
two episodes of that show no big [ __ ]
deal
you see him at home sweet home alone the
pete holm show 43 episodes of that baby
he's got his own comedy central presents
premium blend late night with jimmy
fallon your mom's house not safe with
nikki glazer last call with carson daly
wtf joe rogan larry king
inside jokes hot ones jimmy kimmel lived
at today's show ellen cbs saturday
morning good morning america 14
appearances on [ __ ] conan
lights out with david spade the late
show the talk and entertainment tonight
he has many specials out nice try the
devil
face and sounds
dirty clean
and he's also the host of you made it
weird and one of the stars of the brand
new cbs hit how we roll do me a favor
and not to mention he's got a little bit
of that e-trade money do me a favor give
it up for the one the only peter
[Applause]
holy [ __ ]
i was just supposed to [ __ ] that up i
can tell you right now
wow
too much stuff
[Laughter]
i only saw dollar signs to be honest
with you
that was really tiring to hear
because every those were words too but
every line was a memory yeah like you'd
be like ellen and i i met samuel l
jackson and ellen they just flashed it's
not a good story
[Laughter]
i walked in and there was sam like if
you were on ellen round of applause
you're on ella
you guys know when you're on alice sam
jackson is in the other green room do
you go in clap if yes
that's uh yeah clap if no just to
identify yourself as a cool ass
[ __ ]
you wouldn't go with this guy's happy no
way
what if you're just like not a fan
uh i went in with the tangle hat on with
a kick i don't ask if he had cankles yes
he did have cankles he needs to work his
lower body
pete went for the big high five my man
oh my god
i uh don't recall what i did for the
greeting but i remember that as soon as
i said hello i was like i gotta get out
of here
like what am i doing wasting this
person's time
buddy thank you so much for coming and
sitting down with me appreciate it give
people one more big round of applause
again thank you for having me
thank you we got a little [ __ ] star
power in this
you just tell the sam joint story and
leave
well i felt like it was hot enough
it was like a closer of a story always
be closing dude i don't want to go
greedy um give us the full scoop what's
the pete holm story go back tell us
childhood brother sister's mom
massachusetts kid right massachusetts
yeah i've never said that before
um
yeah that was that's a generous question
i'm from lexington massachusetts
birthplace of the american revolution
you're welcome wow look at that it's a
[ __ ] patriot over here everybody we
lost we reenact that battle every year
we lose every year
and i i don't know i think i can
summarize it pretty quickly i had an
over loving mother and just a
withholding enough father who's also a
gregarious ham that made me want to uh
get in the profession of getting
attention okay you know what i'm saying
i have an older brother
two years older and i also grew up super
religious so when when you go to church
a lot this is going to sound fake but
you see
a pastor speaking and occasionally
getting laughs oh yeah that really like
you know like brandy like they're always
like i started singing in church there's
a comedy equivalent where you're like
they let me go up i would do i know it
didn't date well or age well but i do a
cosby impression and all these things
at church
what
that's two worlds crossing right there
it wasn't catholic you son of a [ __ ]
this guy's doing rodney dangerfield he's
killing
but i mean you could only do clean stuff
so i would do zip dip and pudding pops
and all that and that's awesome that's
where the bugs started you know buckets
going around the church real quick
trying to get some tips it was a rich
church we did have buckets instead of
baskets
golden buckets
what was the house like growing up
single-family homes suburbs right uh
single family yeah i thought you meant
single parent no yeah yeah yeah i'll
scare you
um no no offense to all of the single
the guy who didn't want some of the guys
in the back i said the birthplace of the
american revolution didn't
yeah my parents uh are still together
unfortunately and
we were raised in uh
i would say
i mean like from the outside it looked
great we lived in like this old sort of
haunted looking victorian house but
there was a lot of fighting i didn't
know that that wasn't normal is this the
flavor of the body yeah we like it for
sure yeah what do you mean
well what comedians do i just do a ted
talk tedx let's not flatter myself it's
a tedx talk um
off-brand
but every night was incredibly tense my
mom was waiting for my dad to get home
he was maybe at the bar
he comes home we have this meal and like
that's where you hone the skill of like
noticing how everyone feels sure and i
feel like in the room reading the room
yeah so that's what i do for a living
that's why when i started doing like
comedy clubs and it would be like the
midnight show at [ __ ] helium and
philadelphia
and they're like it's a little rowdy and
i'm like you don't have [ __ ] on dad yeah
you know what i mean is my drunk dad out
there then we're good it was like
it was simultaneously the scariest thing
to a performer and it's also like the
best thing you can do because you're
reclaiming your you sure you're you're
you're in the situation that you
couldn't control so it makes perfect
sense that you got in a business of
trying yeah to control a situation yeah
and this is everything people who make
tv direct tv write tv people do stand up
people who act they all tend to be a
little bit of control freaks sure
because it's insane oh it's a wild
career path
it's insane it's for lunatics first of
all we ask you to clap before we've done
anything
one more time for pete exactly you asked
them to clap twice
two imagine if i wrote like it's it's
possible let's say something happens one
of you comes up and slaps me and this
becomes a huge benchmark moment in my
life and then i later write a movie
about it okay well then it would be
insane like i would be like
um wild applause
he turns to the crowd makes eyes with
the most beautiful woman she winks
like
what kind of lunatic
you just like and then
they kev comes up to me and goes you
were the best guest we have ever had
and i knew then yeah that's insane it is
it's what and that's what we do we try
to keep it a little more somebody get a
treatment together for that will you for
god's thanksgiving
treatment
inside info i like it
your parents still live on the same
street to the same house
they moved okay so this will get us into
our garbage
i i enjoy the pod and uh you already had
us with the dinner fights by the way
just so you know we're already there
yeah i can handle a tough room spaghetti
flying across the room was a dead
giveaway you ever spill milk all over
the meatloaf oh that's a tough spot i'm
gonna give you a big clue i think i
don't know if i'm garbage but a big clue
is when i wanted to eat my feelings it
was triscus oh
that's a fancy cracker that's all right
i knew you would like that yeah it was
triscuit hey ritz kick rocks will ya
that's we're at triscuit's house he's
not eating combos like a dirt bag
what am i at a rest stop i'm not eating
combos
dude i eat them at every rest stop yeah
that's when you're allowed to eat sure
we're talking olive oil and basil fat
reduced the good stuff ooh fat reduced
doesn't help you with those carbs though
uh is that a green light area um i
didn't know
why i went for it
that's what the show's built on um
there's a lot of fat jokes and a couple
of bald jokes yes
so oh and it was with tropicana orange
juice because that was salty sweet
people think that's insane if you eat
triscuits and every once in a while
we're talking like a gentleman's sip
just a little just a little reminder
that life can also be sweet
your mouth is cut up [ __ ] cap and
crunch gets all the credit for cutting
up the
roof [ __ ] will [ __ ] you up
that [ __ ] comes in looking for captain
crunch and cuts his ear off
that's the captain now
i apologize but it was these are premium
uh these are pretty in the 80s and 90s
like tropicana there's a hundred percent
talking what kind of pulp level you're
doing on the tropicana back then it was
pulp or no pulp it was zero pogo
wow you know you know what i'll do if i
want some [ __ ] pulp i'll eat a
goddamn orange
you know that was a mistake that's like
the oops all berries of drinks
they're like this has all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] in it just say it's 20 pulp yeah
[ __ ] gross
uh what was i telling you i don't
remember
do you remember i don't but the triskets
was great um
my father what'd your dad do for what
your parents do for a living okay yeah
this is this is good intel because i
really wanna find out and i'm gonna take
your word for it at the end um my mother
is from south boston okay ever heard of
it i had the departed there's no
triscuits down there i can tell you that
so that's [ __ ] a right it's a nilla
wafer kind of neighborhood my mother
gets your ass kicked in a triscuit
hey what are you eating a tristan what
are you queer that's what it is
charlene knock this [ __ ] kid out will
you hey fancy boy you want something to
cut up your mouth i got some red
then he takes out his grated dick
what a terrible person
why would he it doesn't seem worth it
for the insult to reveal that you have a
cheese grater
i enjoyed the riff a lot of you backed
up
i don't think if you're if you're not
loving you're not picturing a boy who's
trying to bully me he's high status he's
a bully he takes out his dick it has
grates on it rough yes i'm in pete i'm
on board okay unfortunately
i feel like i'm doing a comic-con panel
well actually a lot of the effects were
in camera
[Laughter]
so my mother when she was seven years
old uh left lithuania a war-torn
lithuanian world war ii ever heard of
him
so she left lithuania uh the whole thing
ellis island got the [ __ ] she's got the
manifest in our in our uh dining room
and so then she moved to south boston
where uh not to bum you all out but like
boston finds ways to be racist to others
sure branches
yeah exactly and if your last name is
wait what was it i'm not saying it again
that's my [ __ ] citibank password
you can all regret saying it the first
time
we'll be
but she would get like rocks and [ __ ]
thrown at her and stuff so she was like
uh a tough broad and also a little bit
um shook by the whole world of course so
then she meets my [ __ ] father i
haven't dropped his ass he's [ __ ] my
[ __ ] father's in cape cod my father's
a self-made guy they both have the
accent they both have their own okay i
didn't even know
i didn't have the accent until i watched
all those movies
i saw goodwill hunting and i'm like how
do you like them apples
the proper way to say it matthew
but my kind of scarlet
but my parents both had it have it they
still have it and um so she meets my
[ __ ] father
in cape cod okay he was vacationing
because he's a self-made guy so he was
at cape cod
he summers in cape cod maybe it was the
fall
[Laughter]
he goes when he has a weekend free when
he gets a monday off he goes okay i
didn't say he was a [ __ ] kennedy what
are you doing to me yeah they weren't
fancy pants but my father uh lost his
father when he was the age was always
whatever age i was so when i was 12 he
was like when i was 12 my father died
13. when i was 13 my father died the
story got worse dad's this guy hat what
the hell pop
so he takes over when he's like 15. he
takes over my father's home heating oil
delivery company and drove the truck
hooked up the hose from the east coast
he takes over his great you take your
grandfather's business he takes over my
grandfather's business hardcore but then
he gets a loan from a wonderful man
named mr hurley who gave him like i
don't know what it was let's say it was
ten thousand dollars in a brown paper
bag is the story so his last name
probably wasn't hurley i can't it was
i can't say it
but it was mr hurley gives my dad a
brown paper bag of cash and my dad uses
that money real american dream [ __ ] to
buy an apartment building that he still
owns
and there's now probably i don't know
what it's worth but it's worth a lot
like somerville which at the time wasn't
that great sure it's where like i think
it's where triple o's like the ba
[ __ ] whitey bulger used to go
i'm pretty sure that was in summer you
look after them like they're your buddy
from growing up yeah you guys [ __ ]
remember
um so this is important they they meet
in freaking cape cod kid and then they
get my mom
not messing around like quickly i think
says to my dad [ __ ] or get off the pot
like six dates in or something they get
[ __ ] married and then i'm born and
then my dad
uh we lived in melrose which is you know
pretty nice but he wanted to move to
lexington massachusetts where the
wherever
and
lexington you may know from the movie
the fighter
in the movie the fighter
mack wahlberg takes a girl
to lexington to see him right the fancy
movie yeah yeah you [ __ ] remember
so it was like four years ago little fun
fact that's the lexington flick that's
where i worked okay
but in that [ __ ] movie
uh the girl says to mark wildeberg's
character said you didn't have to take
me all the way to hoity toity lexington
now that's what my father liked about
lexington
he if you meet all my relatives they're
they're like they're they're a lot
they're very very very very very boston
i love them very much and then there's
me and my brother and we're like good
afternoon smitty
you're working at the holy toy it's
because he moved us to [ __ ]
hoity-toity lexington and sent us to
private school so my father with his bag
of 10 g's
interrupted
like
generation of course
it wasn't necessarily poverty but it was
certainly generational like you never
leave boston sure your mother's your
number one girl join the union and do
that's a real quote
my cousin raymond said well at my first
wedding he was like you get married but
never forget your mother's your number
one
[Music]
and guys real talk you're actually i
talk a lot of [ __ ] about my parents
because it's fun and they have a good
sense of humor sure they can take it i
hope that was my manager dave i think
well we got him here pete folks come on
come on out if you got them here it
would take my mom 65 minutes to get from
the door i heard you talking [ __ ] all
the way on the court
talking about cape quad
i was trying to yes hand and i blew it
listen
i forget what i was saying i'm so
generous wait i was there my mom oh
broke the generation yes uh sent us to
private school in cambridge uh sent us a
lexington high school all these things
so
that set this precedent
and this is the love that i have for my
parents apart from who they are of
course i love them but also they made it
okay to leave boston which is sure it's
big sure like
i had no issue leaving boston at all
like because i i saw them being sort of
fluid we weren't from the same street in
the same block with the same kids living
next to your cousins with scorsese
narrating
being like i know i normally do italians
in new york but i've been hired for this
and time's a lean and that cintrix money
has gone away
okay let's talk about bespoke post baby
bespoke posts what do you know about the
box of awesome they got over there the
best box in the biz that box of awesome
it's good stuff it's springtime gang
uh-huh get your box of awesome you got
outdoor stuff you got grooming materials
you got things for the bar it's cool guy
stuff yeah at a discounted rate i know
and what a lot of it's done by small
businesses they get the cream of the
crop put it all together in one box they
send it over to you yeah they sent us a
bunch of stuff you got cool designer
products like you said small batch kind
of operate i got a cool knife you got
the hammock we got a tent i got a bag
that i take on the road with me wore the
hammock last night
uh to get started just take the quiz at
box of awesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
for you they release new boxes every
month across a ton of different
categories whether it's like you said
the bar barbecue you show up to a
barbecue correct or something from box
of awesome each box is valued at around
70 but you only pay a fraction of that
price plus with each box of awesome like
you said you're supporting small
business 90 of everything that comes in
your box of awesome is from a small
up-and-coming brand look at that get 20
off your first monthly box when you sign
up at box of awesome dot com enter code
garbage at check out that's box of
awesome dot com code garbage for 20 off
your first box box of awesome.com go
garbage do it movement baby movement
watches movement watches that's not the
best best in the biz started out two
friends
college dropouts yeah tiny apartment
wanted to take the watch game by storm
and they did that they did it a couple
of bozos made good and now what it's
grown into what everything you go to the
website you get some shades get a nice
watch at a fraction of the cost again
fraction of the cost it's good stuff it
looks sharp they sent it to us my wife
calls it my fancy watch i wear it after
nice nice when i go to a wedding or a
nice din din where my fancy watch shout
out to movement baby sure movement
watches have a look and quality of a
four to five hundred dollar watch but
you're paying
a watch you're paying for at a
department store but at a fraction of
the cost there you go of the price
because they were built online with
their own process from start to finish
no middleman the beginning of the end
movement has you you get a beautiful
watch to break your door for free check
it out you don't love it you can ship it
right back for free as well they got the
blue light glasses if you spend all day
in front of a computer they're good my
wife uses them bang bang bang bang she's
working remotely takes care of the eyes
the birds are always coming home my eyes
are bothering me get the glasses glasses
you choose uh if you want to elevate
your look with a style that doesn't
break the bank then join movement and
get 50 off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to mvmt.com
garbage one more time that's mvmt.com
garbage do it yeah so
they when i was 22
i moved to chicago chicago chicago
because that's where improv was okay and
that's what i wanted to do
you tell me what area you'd like to go
into
i like how he's conducting this i feel
like wilford brimley and you guys are
just at my dinner party and i'm like no
one else can talk let's go back to the
let's go back to the 10 g's and the
hefty back i think yeah sure no i see
exactly what you're saying they moved
out now your other the other friends
that you had the friends that you that
you got in lexington that was a little
more hoity-toity were they more they had
a little more generational wealth
because even though you guys had the
money you still had to go home every
night and you're having the fights at
dinner so the garbage still follows you
a little bit in the home that's a little
bit you can
take 10 g's out of south boston but yeah
out of my parents not without a knife
not without a nice vigor on it i'll tell
you that right now
look
i i don't mean to be this guy but i'm
like i wouldn't change a thing sure and
they did they didn't get along they
still don't really get along they've
just surrendered
yeah
that's real love as far as
you gotta hang out at some point they've
like wilted they're just like ah [ __ ] it
and they're just like they sleep in
different floors
ah that's awesome and my dad is
currently he can't stop going to the
cooperstown baseball hall of fame solo
he's there solo
[Laughter]
and he texted me and he was like this is
a new change for me
i can do whatever i want whenever i want
i'm going to cooper's town and you know
what i don't care what she says i was
reading the text and vowel my wife was
there and i was like i don't know what
to reply and we decided on steve harvey
and family feud blinking in disbelief
and it was the right choice
to answer your question when we got to
lexington yes there was more money
certainly right at the private school
this is when i started meeting a lot of
kids yep that had you know
yeah
and then so this is the i said this with
love this is the garbagey thing my
father
is now thrust into am i pitching a movie
right now
but my father is thrust into the upper
crust
study at her house and my father would
be in these bible studies and this is a
true story in the middle of bible study
he goes past uh he probably wasn't
listening for 10 minutes he didn't even
know if it was a good window to
interrupt he was like pastor everyone's
like okay when you go to the bathroom do
you uh did you play with your dude to do
what the [ __ ] this is at a church bible
study
and like marianne mitchner you can't
make these names up there with their
high hair marianne michener goes what
and he goes you know that's when you go
in the bathroom and you get the empty
toilet paper roll and you put it up to
your lips and go tada
so
that's my dad to say another love this
guy's [ __ ] awesome dude
he absolutely is like there's so much
about him that i love and one of the
things is he doesn't change who he is
for other people
and he has this incredible power he was
in politics when he was a young man and
even though he was still incredibly
working class he was never slick like a
kennedy but he did uh hold a seat in
city council or something all right here
we go here we are nice and we had
aspirations you wanted to be a kennedy
i'm sure you wanted to be a fancy guy um
he also changes the temperature of a
room he's one of those guys that i would
watch him walk into lindell's bakery and
like
like everything would just come to him
yeah and now i'm not pitching a movie
but if i do pitch a movie there's like
the subtle art of
you don't want to like take
control like we hate cocky people
we like um warm people warm assured
people people that are assured in their
own worth you know what i'm saying and
my father has that a cocky guy is like
all right netflix shut the [ __ ] up james
bond meets big mouth he's horny there's
a demon he's following him he's shooting
dicks off he's got a cheese grated dick
i'll call it back if you don't like it
that's a pro move right that's a pro
move
but actually we could talk a little bit
but that is something my father would do
is if something was embarrassing or bad
he would he would revisit it yeah get
out in front of it yeah that's it's like
in jazz there's no mistake if you do it
again and he's really that kind of guy
and then my mother
she was she's the hardest core snob in
the world i can't wait to give you the
list of things we couldn't do
really married with children
are you farting a lot of washington yeah
simpsons no [ __ ] way fried dough
professional wrestling roller coasters
staying out past ten rolling rock beer
did you say fried dough fried dough the
recipe can't be the dish
[Laughter]
the recipe can't be the dish you need
some ingredients that's just like eating
melted cheese yeah that makes
sense putting cheese on doritos get out
of here horror movies bikini contests
well i mean who's doing that a lot of
these [ __ ] are going to
hardcore bikini what normal seventh
grader can't go to the bikini contest
with his friend yeah joel and i had a
white t-shirt contest that's it all
right well wet t-shirt contest yeah now
you're cooking absolutely so since they
don't live there anymore what was the
actual name of the street that you grew
up on bloomfield bloomfield street ave
what was it get the [ __ ] out of here
bloomfield street street yeah all right
bloomfield's fancy though expect a
little more out of a lexington man but
okay
they say it was near slocum road
s-o-l-c-u-m
slo-cum
that one got stole quite a bit
how about the grocery store was the name
of the grocery store shopping shop
swapping shopkins
go to starbucks that's a great question
for for what we're interested in today
because there's [ __ ] market basket
market basket and they're stop and shop
and if you're really [ __ ] fancy
you're going to go to super stock and
shop
super stoppage yeah that's invite only i
think
who makes a class system within their
own company like that
we got the riffraff and stop and shove
or a super stopping shot
it's true though i don't think my mother
would set foot in the marketplace
that's the track market basket trashy
the lower end this is what's interesting
about the topic of the show is like all
these things are branded with these
conversations in mind like lexus is a
made-up word sure like we want to be for
the new money and mercedes is for the
old money and subaru is for the lesbians
can i say
we all love a good outback let's not be
ridiculous here what is that too much or
you austin oh i'm sorry that's the new
move in comedy do you i just get
canceled yeah no one cares about you
ain't there any unfunny jokes oh too
much yeah that was one of my save lines
when i would do open mics i thought it
was so funny when a comedian would tell
a horrible joke about granola it
wouldn't work and he'd go oh i'm sorry
do you all harvest granola
yeah no it couldn't be that it just was
a bad joke we harvest granola
yeah there's a better chance we all
harvest granola than that joke stinking
pete what was the car situation going on
he did one more kim
that was good what was the car situation
going up what'd you guys roll around
then you are i mean you're really
nailing it you've done this before we
my father i like how pete keeps telling
us oh that's good for the show
this would be great this would be great
for a garbage podcast if you ever do one
i know but we all assume there's a later
what if this is it
you know what i mean you're like i don't
need to hear that i'm going to do a
million more what if we all die right
now
i forget people get freaked out it could
happen i'm saying it makes it imbues the
moment with vitality and it makes it
precious it makes your ice cream taste
better if you go like plain
[Laughter]
don't be afraid we're all in this
together we're all delicate flowers all
right
my father had a 1985 scout truck so he
had like kind of like a working class
okay
mom then uh she was a terrible driver
white knuckling praying out loud as she
made lefts onto mass avenue
talk about making a kid nervous what the
[ __ ] i'm sitting there and she's like
dude he says please take out no wonder
i'm so comfortable talking about doubt
you're rolling the dice in every turn as
we burn please keep it quick
[Music]
please take us through asphyxiation and
not through the crisping of our skin
you got a high c in your mouth like what
the [ __ ] lady
just get me to basketball practice wait
i mean we laugh it's a vivid memory
i know but she bought a volvo you see
what they're trying to do they're trying
to go up sure of course it was probably
an idea he takes the truck to work she
drives the volvo around station wagon
now would they ever have those were
awesome but they ever have the
confidence to get like a benz or a la or
like because the volvo is the
conservative i have a little bit of cash
i want to show you that i have it but
i'm not
over the top flaunting it so my father's
in that type of business where it's like
i think he's flush one day and then
maybe it's like i had the same
upbringing and when he's flush i think
we did we got a mercedes they used
mercedes yeah like 1995.
and i remember driving it and feeling
like this is illegal i'm 17.
i'm just like doing
big turns in the mercedes it was
incredible and he had a 51 chevy because
he started collecting and fixing cars
damn yeah this guy's all right i thought
the 51 i vividly remember being a little
kid and thinking that the radio and the
chevy should only play oldies
like i was like well it's an old radio
green day
that's that's what it should play
but when it was green day i was like
this is inappropriate we did kenny
loggins getting here we did listen to
oldies oldies 103.3
sorry they're a sponsor go to oldies103
backslash weird for 10 off free radio
for all your oldies needs
that's 103. okay
but then he'd get like a porsche like an
old porsche to fix up but it would be in
the garage like for forever 20 years
yeah were any of these cars ever on the
front yard or on the side yard not
parked did you see the driveway
i'm resisting complimenting your
question
i have a bit that never works uh it
might work on this podcast it's really
just a thought it's not even informed
enough to be able but i'm like rich
people very rich people and very poor
people have a lot in common yes they
both love cologne
they
like the middle group no cologne but
very rich very poor lot of cologne
um they both have access to nature
like the people in the middle very hard
to get nature but like if you're very
rich you live on a ranch if you're very
poor you live in a field
[Music]
[Applause]
you live in the woods the covid approach
was very similar in both groups and then
the last one was like you own more than
two cars yeah very rich people have like
seven weeks
very poor people always have like nine
cars
more of a junkyard kind of vibe yes
that
you know add up to one good car so you
had a couple around the house we had a
couple they weren't in the yard that
would not be allowed but we did have a
lot of unfinished construction work yeah
that was being a lot of unfinished
construction work yeah okay sorry little
garbage we're getting there a little
garbage we're getting were you guys a
shoe zone in the house
family i think it was dealer's choice
but we took it
it was dealer's choice i didn't have a
mom that was like you know what those
have been it wasn't like okay it was
like take them off because you're
comfortable no tv in your room i would
assume right tv in my room until i got
into shooting my own videos and then i
convinced them to get me a tv off the
want ad which was ebay but a print form
and i got an old tv from my bedroom and
on that tv i watched my first
pornography that i found in my brother's
room in an orange there we go orange and
gray two-toned shoebox yeah and i i was
religious so i would put the tapes in my
camcorder hook it up to my tv watch if
the vertical hold would be off so it'd
be two lesbians 69 and that's really
what it was that was the first image i
saw not a good start
and they were going by and i'd have my
way with it oh god that was terrible
i'd uh have my way with it we'd have our
time but then you know the whole time
playing with your dude to do
he won
a podcast award just now
bring it out
uh they don't have if he's ridiculing me
or not no that was amazing
i know i can't get a read on this guy
he's like the sphinx this guy's bob goes
for sure i would worry that jesus would
come back while i was j j
for yeah try a cup of decaf will you
the devil is named after i didn't want
to have my ham and my sandwich when
jesus comes out out of the clouds on a
golden sheep pursuing my own coming
while he the second coming he's just
he's the same thing he won't masturbate
if somebody he knows is on an airplane
that's great i only masturbate when
somebody's on an airplane i'm like
matter of fact delta 40
sorry no no no no no no
that's it pete that's it all right
but i but i certainly wasn't allowed to
watch tv okay
did you pack a lunch to school or did
you buy lunch there pack a lunch until
high school then i bought lunch was the
did you have like a brown bag or did you
have a lunch box box yeah yeah
all right so it wasn't so terrible over
there you could watch your he-man i
didn't like your dirty movies but milk
in the thermos i didn't care for that
remember
remember when our mom would put milk in
the thermos
it doesn't stay cold no that's a tough
look but you'd have milk with dinner
milk with dinner yeah that's
that's garbage let me give you another
detail
uh the the gallon uh would be on the
table one gallon of milk on the table at
dindin yeah
that's the european and your mom they
leave that [ __ ] out for months yeah
just warm milk at dinner eggs on top of
the refrigerator it would keep it's cool
it's sweating for sure
well that's just the tension of the
fight
even the milk's nervous
somebody tell a joke or something will
ya pete hit it
but i drank milk for hydration until i
was 28
like i would go to other people's houses
and they would give me water and i'd be
like what is this the dust bowl
are are you going through lean times
bring out the cow milk hey lady i do two
percent or higher you know what i mean
i'd come home from basketball and drink
milk that's awesome gotta get your bones
strong yeah because of the campaign it
was and then water had this huge
turnaround renaissance
and now
i'm about it
[Laughter]
you guys go big into christmas
yeah [ __ ] a uh colored lights outside
or white lights ooh colored ooh
big tree or real tree
i'm gonna i'm gonna come back yeah okay
real tree okay so colored lights are
trash yeah of course yeah and they were
just the ones you're picturing yeah yeah
yeah they kind of they have like a film
on them yeah the glass wasn't dyed it's
a regular bulb and then they put they
wrapped them and wrapped like the size
of a tennis ball or something like that
yeah three of them are out by the time
you get them home i like how i was like
i'm pretty classy out in the back i was
like all right we'll get there
drinking milk at halftime yeah
yeah
saltines with american cheese and milk
was a snack off whoa
and i remember the white flower rush
of that
nightmare of a snack chasing dairy with
dairy
[Laughter]
with like a mushy saltine going down
like what is this a nursing home
just put it all in the blender and get
it over with is there a pizza it really
cakes up in there too oh yeah gross
really gross
kevin butcher box butcher box what's in
your freezer butcher box uh is it top
quality meats that takes the guesswork
out of everything
huh yeah it is does it save you time
yeah does it save you money yeah do you
like 45 pounds of ground beef
because i know i do i know and i got
some in the freezer right now listen
butcher box is a subscription-based
meat supplier uh-huh chicken turkey wild
caught salmon uh-huh the whole
nine-year-old guy grass i love that
grass-fed grass finish we're talking
top-quality stuff yeah grill it you can
smoke it put it in the oven or you can
do what i do you could eat it frozen
they sent it they sent me and you it
seems to be about 7 000 pounds of meat
i'm still working through it it's wild
it's fantastic it's delicious everybody
loves it every month butcher box ships a
curated selection of high quality meat
right to your home free shipping for the
continental us no antibiotics no
hormones each box contains 8 to 14
pounds of meat depending on the box you
choose let's be honest with the supply
chain the way it is these days you don't
really know what you're getting in the
grocery you go to the grocery store
sometimes they got stuff sometimes they
don't you're like hey buddy wear the
meatballs yeah what i mean it could be a
teenager's finger you don't know what
the [ __ ] you're getting butcher box
takes all that away it's packed fresh
[ __ ] frozen for convenience so you can
save time on your next grocery store
trip customize your own box or go with
one of theirs either way you get exactly
what you want this is your chance to nev
this is wild take if you're driving pull
over this is insane this is your chance
to never have to shop for ground beef
again that's right butcher box is giving
new members free ground beef for life
hey buddy they know the show one last
thing you gotta think about plus you get
a ten dollar off coupon sign up for
butcherbox.com ayg to get two pounds of
ground beef in every order for the rest
of your life of your members
plus ten dollar off coupon log on to
butcherbox.com ayg to claim this deal do
it go ahead kid let's talk about
atlantic green athletic greens athletic
greens or as we know on the as we call
it on the streets agy yeah you got that
ag-1 on you i can tell you why i started
taking it why is that big as we all know
cause i'm a big fat pig hey and i had to
start working out it's all that
groundbreaking and i started working
it's all that free ground beef
and i started working out i noticed that
i was tired during my workouts
and my trainers like you should bring a
bottle of water with you i was like i'll
do you one better i got you we got this
new sponsors months ago i got this new
sponsor gg1 ag-1 take care started
bringing it with me powers me through my
workouts here that's all the [ __ ]
proof i need right there take a pc
button zoom in on the guns
the pipes are out they're bursting yes
plumber uh ag-1 is 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole foods source
superfoods probiotics and adaptogens
whatever they may or may not be it's
like a super duper multivitamin what are
we doing take it everybody's taking a
thousand pills nowadays you don't need
to do that you just take ag-one it's
easy gut health immunity the whole nine
yards yeah it supports mental clarity
alertness supports better sleep recovery
no gmos no nasty chemicals still taste
good uh whether you're keto paleo vegan
dairy-free or gluten-free it takes care
of you easy peasy lemon squeezy to make
it easy athletic greens are going to
give you a free one-year supply of
immune of immune supporting vitamin d
and five free travel plaques for your
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com garbage again
that's athletic greens.com garbage to
take ownership over your health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
insurance today
now do it
back to the show back to the show
welcome back to the show
all right uh first concert
i remember my first well i think we went
to see dan fogelberg with my dog okay
you know what that is
i've heard of him yeah
and then we'd go and see handel's
messiah see that's them trying that's
the hallelujah chorus they try and class
us up with that okay but then my first
concert now i'm 17. you bought the first
one you bought a ticket yeah yours ah
oh great question well it was a it was a
free show it was green day it's funny
that you said wow okay it was green day
and then i got obsessed with punk rock
and i started going to the middle east
which was an all-ages punk club and i
would see all these really really
hardcore same as the actual middle east
hills i was like
there were a big punk rock over there
the middle east all the good shows are
in saudi arabia dude
everybody knows that
they do a lot of the songs from aladdin
right this covers
punk they do it and they do it punk and
there was a big full screen apology i
don't know if you've watched that on
disney plus lately but there's a big
apology oh really before robin williams
is like hello welcome to my business
in a voice that if i did accurately
would be a problem
um
and then rant said rancid was a big
first there you go that's a good one
that's a really good one yeah yeah
first job
lexington flick
well that's right okay hoity toity movie
theater yeah it's just solid that's a
solid gig there yeah what'd you get on
your sats oh good question
hesitating
spit it out here i'll make you feel
better
i got an 870.
thank you
[Laughter]
i don't know that's supposed to make me
feel
dumb
no i wanted [ __ ] that [ __ ] man you're a
host of a great popular podcast you won
i won two i got a 10 40.
i got anything
that's good four digits four digits yes
that's good all of my friends were 13
and higher yeah because you grew up in a
wealthy area yes and they all took sat
prep
yeah i bought
flash cards out of the back of a
magazine what like my parents just
didn't know what the sats were and i was
like i think i should be studying but
then i just kept going into my brother's
shoe box
your dad just kept telling you to do
push-ups to get ready for it yes exactly
do more sit-ups you'll be fine
i uh and then i i did those flashcards
took him again and got a 1040. nice
that's great yeah that's great the
middle of the curve baby that's good i
was ready to be ridiculed oh
i mean i got an 11 40 but you know it's
just me okay
well i got my name wrong and that's 200
points
how was the uh what were the holmes
family vacations like jeez would you go
up to cape cod
[ __ ] you dude yeah
why are you doing this to me we did have
a cottage in the cave
and we would go there and this sounds
like a a line from a short story or like
a nov like an autobiography and it's
like those summers were glorious
my father would work during the week and
we'd be alone with mother
and they were i mean i love my dad but
like my family always works better when
one of them is removed gotcha that's
still true right that's cool me my dad
my mom great me my mom my brother great
me my brother my dad great i can't
believe i did it but all four of us yeah
it's not it's like chemistry it just
doesn't work so switch off and shifts i
get it then
my father gets a [ __ ] winnebago whoa
and we start taking trips to montreal
and [ __ ] the worst trips of my life it
was it was horrible where did you park
to winnebago
great
i'm sorry but are you serious
these are great questions
i mean that like you could ask me was
your dad drinking you could ask me was
it tight or you could say where did you
park and know the answer when i say
diagonally across four handicapped spots
like
that's where it was
okay that paints quite a picture i can
tell you that
he would get to tolls he'd lose the
ticket i'll do the ticket you know the
ticket he'd lose the ticket and they're
like well it's 98 and it'd go kiss my
ass and blow it through
and he'd have us look out the back
window for cops and when we cross state
lines he'd relax a little bit
this guy's [ __ ] hard what happened to
church in the pastor you're playing
lookout on a highway run and my mom is
mortified of course i mean it was a lot
it was a lot would he ask for when he
did have the ticket and pay the toll
would he ask for a receipt no no okay
because [ __ ] rock and roll yeah
i'm not paying it anyway
yeah
yeah yeah okay
the winnebago
it's not helping you what was the the
cape sounded nice though yeah cape was
nice it's like the duality of man right
now cape cod but then parking an illegal
winnebago and my it's like we're in the
departed i like it my father
i would go to this restaurant this
chinese restaurant and he loved it and
the waiter's name was dong and he loved
dong and
i didn't mean that in the way that you
took it it's a five o'clock show guys
it's a matinee come on get your heads
out of the gutter but guys get serious
my dad really loved dog big dog
and he was a hairy guy big hairy dong
was my dad's
absolute favorite and big hairy dung
would bring him things to put in his
mouth and he'd say thank you don thank
you dong and
let me know when you're going to finish
like he meant bring the check but you
know that sort of thing uh so dong
wasn't worth it guys i put my career on
the line with that riff
for a d-minus lap
we'll take care of it in post edit it
out
but uh real talk he loved dong and this
is really sweet and i think it speaks to
this my father invited dong and his
family to the cape and they stayed with
us for like three weeks that's awesome
so whenever i catch myself being like
[ __ ] you dad in my head of course i'm
terrified of him whenever you never say
that i'm like wait a minute this was a
sweet man i relate
especially as you get older yeah and as
i get older i i know what it's like i i
he didn't really he he's not like a big
friend guy
you know what i mean i don't think a lot
of men are it's not modeled for us how
to be like vulnerable it's all jack
reacher i don't dance you know sure like
jason bourne jack reach they never dance
it's because they don't want to be
vulnerable to allow music to manipulate
their body like you have to succumb
especially if that's dancing
you know jason bourne you know yeah
somebody hand me
yeah i also don't think it would
it wouldn't fit in with the vibe of the
movie if he started dancing he might
have danced at a wedding but that wasn't
in the movie you are both very good
but no country for old men the musical i
don't know if that's gonna work
don't put it in your pocket flip a coin
flip a coin flip a coin but what i'm
saying is men don't that was pretty good
that was a good piece of business
[Laughter]
this is used to kill cattle
uh i just wanted to join for fun
but anyway he uh blah blah blah yeah
male friendship isn't really modeled a
lot i don't mean to get too serious but
i didn't see my father do it he sure
should didn't see his father do it and
like it just gets passed on like having
friends is like some weak [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah
you should be like that that that blue
it's like you should be working you
shouldn't be like hanging out with the
guy it's like working your wife is your
one friend because you're gonna make
babies with her and like that's kind of
haunting to me like i i i have friends
but it's not natural to me i'm not i'm
not like sometimes my guy friends are
like you want to hang out i'm like you
mean do a podcast
[Music]
because that's that's more comfortable
to me i'm not sure i'm not proud of it
but that's true that's good that's a
good work ethic i also will do like
random like i met a guy at uh a park
you know i met a guy at huntington
gardens and like we just hit it off we
were talking about our kids and i was
like what are you doing next thursday
let's meet back here and we did like
that's fantastic i'll do like dong moves
like my dad
but i struggle to call joey rose's our
friend joe derozan
but yeah so he's a sweet man don okay
[Laughter]
do you want to you want to switch to a
little bit of now i do i want to know
now all right i want to know i want to
know how you operate now
you're down in the scorecards
from the past just to let you know oh
i'm trash you're not classy love it
i was really worried because my mom is a
real snob so a lot of that got in me and
what was her name again
well her first name is
you might say
because you're a [ __ ] idiot
i'm talking to 11 40 over here pete
i'm not no 1020 or whatever you do
you're like a ninja with one of those
like crossbelts filled with stars i
can't believe that it's a big compliment
thank you very much the real toby cut
that send it to me
you're the limited edition student
you live on cali yeah house apartment
i live in a house it wasn't a house
after all those credits you think he's
living in a [ __ ] apartment this guy's
got house money probably in the hills
somewhere i just wanted to see i would
react
trying to get this guy on his heels the
disgusting
okay house excellent
what kind i assume you have a car it's
outlay right i'm not asking the kind of
the car no i'll tell you it's a volvo i
thought it was funny because my mom oh
there you go we have a very travel yeah
i drive an audi my my wife drives a
volvo out okay there we go
it's not like an s3 it's a q3 which is
like
i remember buying it i was like this is
like ten thousand dollars more than a
jetta it's not like a fancy yeah was
there a crazy i know that's a lot of
money i'm just saying it's not a lane no
it's not true are those things yeah
poor poor people out there
i know you've responded driving dirtbag
some of you have cars that are
sure yeah worth 35 000 it's not a fancy
car
am i nuts no no no
you're totally you're totally fine
you're fine you don't have to buy it out
right you know you can lease it although
you put ten percent down what's the
matter although here's something for
your notes i bought it out right
good piece of [ __ ] peter
i bought both of them outright same day
i don't give a [ __ ]
ribbon on the top kept it in moshe
cash's garage christmas morning snuck
out got it parked it in the driveway
like a [ __ ] that's like the
commercial like a commercial because val
is the best she's not like she's not a
showbiz jerk she's like she still
experiences and feels things so it was
so fun
to surprise her and and it was great not
the best gift i got her the best
christmas gift ever if you guys know any
artist it's a great way to support
artists too my friend uh i always
confuse him with his brother it's jeremy
hoffeld i commissioned him to do a
portrait of val and our daughter from a
photo wow and she opened that and and
wept it was way better than the car
that's pretty so that's the best gift
faultful guy i like doing gifts for vale
i think my girlfriend would want the car
to be honest with you
well you know what yeah the painting's
cute where's the benzo fanny so it's
natasha and moshe had that car in their
garage for like five five six days
and natasha goes mosha got me an ipad
she just has to see the better present
every day i know you're just flexing on
this dude yeah it was uh it was bad you
got her an air fryer is that right
what kind of air freshener you got in
the car pete i don't what no air
freshener no okay you get a detail get
it washed on a regular basis
if i'm in a very good mood in fact
here's how i know i'm in a very good
mood i'm at the car wash
it always goes if you're driving around
you're just like i am beautiful you want
your car to be clean
but most of the time it's pretty dirty
we park it under a tree that kind of
shits yellow leaves on it
[Laughter]
do you eat your pizza crust yeah what am
i [ __ ] nine
i'm sorry yes i'm a [ __ ] grown man
i eat the crust and you know what i say
to my daughter it's the best part it is
because that's our job as fathers to
continue
with tasteless bread preferences
i know there was a lot of shame in my
house if you didn't eat your crust i
could tell you that yeah have to sleep
in the garage for the night
favorite part of the wing would it be
the drumstick or the actual wing itself
drumstick
and i'll tell you this right now because
you know i learned how to eat chicken
from my mother immigrant mother we
i'm sorry but that that bone is
naked
get after it yeah thank you i i think
that's pretty
pretty gross i
i don't uh you see you're like go you're
like
cartilage we're talking about the guy i
think it's so weird that it's gross to
eat the cartilage but you're eating its
muscle
yeah you know what i mean
you just lost another point
you can say whatever you want people
just think have some respect for this
[ __ ] bird that died for you like
jesus christ of the foul eat it eat its
body it's given to you
he went from an audi to the bone cleaner
real quick real quick
you guys cool on interesting topics
i'm like they'll feel the religious
people will feel seen that i know the
specific religious language but they
were like don't use the name of my god
uh what kind of shampoo do you currently
use i don't wash my hair at all what
kind of body wash you're doing you doing
a bar soap body wash dr bronner's ooh
hoity toity lexington that's like eight
bucks
comes in peppermint i will wash my hair
if i had product in it from a shoot or
something sure but that's the only time
and it's jason it's my wife's shampoo
sounds all right we got one yes jason's
nice she has a thirty five thousand
dollar car
[Laughter]
her husband shaking her head oh no i'm
out of time
do you brush your teeth in the shower
you mean after i finish my core's light
no
like i am disgusted with these questions
[Applause]
you brush your teeth
over your sink which is next to your
wife's sink whoa
you got dual sinks two sinks holy [ __ ]
and i brought him out right
pay cash
[Applause]
oh wow man okay well my next question
you're not gonna like
[Laughter]
do you pee in the shower yeah
this guy's up and down
i have no issue with that i can't get a
[ __ ] read on him at all that's like
the chicken wing yeah
your mom told you how to feed this [ __ ]
down the drain
[Laughter]
he's an interesting mix it's a private
time it's a private time
okay uh
let's see
do you want a tuxedo
i own a black suit and a tuxedo shirt
that i've passed for a tuxedo whoa
that's pretty trashy
how many suits do you have though you
gotta have a bunch of suits right dude
that's [ __ ] crazy
dude i once went to an hbo like uh oscar
or emmy party or something and i looked
down at my pants and i realized they
were unhemmed like they were just the
wrong end you had to roll it was the raw
end of the pants
and i was just at a party and you know
what nobody [ __ ] noticed
yes they did they take their [ __ ]
mouth shut they know that it must be
that new designer oh my god
i started very trendy yeah no you're
helping me that is trashy i agree with
you how many suits do you have though
you gotta have a bunch of suits right i
just got versace the whole nine yards uh
i don't know if they're versace really
uh what
what it's like a guy's name i know
joseph a bank
steve harvey uh j.c penny jc penny
couple of people um oh i know ted baker
no okay it's something like that though
okay samuel jackson
i met him one tell us that story
i don't know i probably own six suits
yeah but you're moving in shea the
premieres and stuff like that yeah
that's good that's good that he's doing
it but let me tell you this this is a
clue i buy them to do things so if you
see me on colbert like i did show you
two weeks ago i'm wearing a new suit i
bought that for that show now let me ask
you this and you only buy them because
you're like well i can't wear the same
suit but if you do watch a bunch of my
youtubes you'll notice i'm often just
wearing the suit i was married in
because it's my favorite suit here's the
thing that's pretty good all right this
is a little hollywood i'm gonna ask you
a question can't wait how much money you
got on you right now
i used to i used to ask that on my talk
show and i would ask rappers sometimes
kid inc did my podcast like 10 grand how
much cash and he had about 10 grand yeah
that's crazy i have about four hundred
dollars on you that's pretty good that's
good yeah um i don't know my voice got
really high when i said that so just to
be clear i need two from me after the
show you can mug me and get 400 rather
easily or you could use my mother's
maiden name and just
digitally when you say that you get
these suits for these events do you
actually get it or does somebody get it
for you and you go and try it on
somewhere
i mean you're right at the you're right
at the cartilage let's eat it i'm
crunching it
you you my friend annie woods who's a
stylist goes and chops for me damn
that's classy but how about that huh she
is my friend and when she brings them
over it's a whole hang we have food we
have dinner she's friend with my wife so
it's not as fancy as it sounds and she
sounds real fancy it's very super stop
and shop to be honest with you
that's not market basket kid how long
were you sitting
[Laughter]
answer me
i don't know when you said it like a
half an hour ago
that is you're very good i'm sorry i
just the [ __ ] quarantine i don't get
to hang out with comedians
i'm just like how are you doing
[Music]
very good
good all right will uh will you send
food back in a restaurant uh no because
my mom did it so much
wow interesting because she probably did
it because she wanted to steam you
rapper it has to be the steak is not
done right it has to be a real egregious
really aggressive yeah of course and
i'll and i'll do you one worse i'll kind
of look down on you if you do
yeah i don't have the confidence to do
it with another comedian she ordered the
mac and cheese she got it she touched it
she went it's cold and i was like it's
probably just cold on top it's probably
piping hot underneath as it [ __ ]
always is yeah so i go just stir it she
goes i shouldn't have to oh
so that's separate checks right there
the [ __ ] out of here honestly i think
that was i would lose it yeah i waited
tables for a long time me too and if you
wait tables
yeah 100 you eat it and shut up you eat
it shut up and you tip well yeah leave
30 yeah i imagine here's another rule if
you do breakfast and the bill is eleven
dollars but you had seventeen coffee
refills and [ __ ] scrambled eggs tip
ten dollars
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you yeah
yeah give them twenty dollars how many
times they came back to your [ __ ]
table yeah i also i've never tipped a
postmate less than 20 bucks the postman
you drove to my house
i made you go host mate postmates i
think i thought you said post man i'm
like you're tipping that guy 20 every
day
this
what
greasing the fedex dude what the [ __ ]
you know why see you're supposed to be
shy about that i'd like to get that out
there oh yes like yeah i don't
understand i go to a restaurant you get
a big meal it's a hundred dollars i now
but you just bring me one plate and one
drink now i owe you twenty dollars this
guy drove to glendale
waited in line got it found parking
found parking at my house brought it to
me it's still hot and he didn't steal
any fries you get 20 bucks yeah
that's very good that's a very classy
move i think we should all be doing it
this side is not clapping they have
fallen on hard times if you vote for me
i will bring more jobs back to austin
and i will keep it weird
ladies and gentlemen
mr pete holmes give a big round of
applause
[Applause]
do i get in the bed do i get a raven
you're [ __ ] trash
peep your garbage i'll tell you right
now [ __ ] litter kid
yeah you're trashy dude come on i never
thought about that you're not classy a
litter box are we calling cat [ __ ] trash
like is that it's discarding its litter
i guess
i don't know the litter is the litter
the litter's the pack i told you i got
an 870. i don't [ __ ] know
but i know you're garbage i can't tell
you that right very much you got your
milk on
[Applause]
i vow to be more garbage when i come
back in one year to the moon
and you guys will both be 20 pounds
lighter
ladies and gentlemen cbs thursdays how
we roll pete holmes everybody
you